j'ai eu la chance d'assister à mes
propres funérailles alors c'était le 15
août 2016 en tout petit comité
seulement avec mes parents qui voulaient
quelque chose de quelque chose de simple
quelque chose de sobre
quelques jours avant ma mort j'étais en
alaska au dessus du cercle polaire
arctique et ça fait plus de deux
semaines que je n'ai pas croisé une
trace humaine
pas de route pas de déchets même pas un
avion dans le ciel rien je suis seul
mais pas tout à fait les ours ne tienne
compagnie et certains sont de véritables
voyons
un os au bond au o o o
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh j'ai rendez vous
sur mon téléphone satellite avec mon
père et ma mère
sauf que j'oublie de les appeler et donc
il en conclut donc que je suis mort et
logiquement comme quiconque ferait il se
met à écrire le discours de mes
funérailles alors ironie de cette
histoire c'était au même moment où mes
parents pleurer mon être c'était
vaillamment battu contre un ours à mains
nues tout de même je suis tombé sur une
mine abandonnée et c'était donc un train
de mon petit frère joyeusement de
conserves périmés pendant que ben mes
parents écrivait leur discours voilà
quelques semaines après je rentre à
rentrer à paris et ont permis son texte
il s'interroge sur la vie d'achille le
héros grec qui a choisi une vie courte
mais glorieuse plutôt qu'une existence
longue mais sans éclat
il se demande s'il a eu raison de vivre
comme ça achille si j'ai eu raison de
dire comme ça moi elliott morts mais
revenons quelques années en arrière
j'ai 20 ans je suis fatigué d'être assis
et je décide de quitter ma classe de
maths sup pour l'australie alors comme
beaucoup de jeunes de mon âge je sais
pas bien quoi faire de ma vie je suis un
peu perdu et je me dis simplement qu'un
qu'un voyage me remettra les idées en
place
en fait ça les a fait exploser mes idées
par accident
je me retrouve plusieurs jours dans une
forêt tropicale avec un paquet de pâtes
pour seules vivant pour la première fois
je découvre la solitude le silence
l'espace la lenteur de la marche et la
vie avec les autres animaux je découvre
aussi que bouffer des pâtes cru pendant
une semaine c'est pas du tout
recommandable et je ne vous recommande
pas mais je suis tellement ébloui par
cette expérience dans la nature sauvage
et que je décide d'en faire mon métier
voilà je serai donc explorateurs l'année
suivante
moi jeune banlieusard de
seine-saint-denis j'atterris à 22 ans en
pleine steppe mongole
alors les choses font que je tombe sur
un cheval complètement instable et
probablement schizophrène ravi de me
[ __ ] des coups de sabots dès qu'il en
a l'occasion
oh
grâce aux nomades
je découvre un mode de vie totalement
autonome on fabrique des cordes avec la
crinière de leurs chevaux les pulls avec
la laine de leurs moutons du fromage de
la crème et même de l'alcool avec le
lait de leur bétail
à ma grande surprise ils passent des
passent des journées entières à ramasser
des bourses de yack alors au début
j'étais un peu surpris je comprenais pas
bien pourquoi ils ont des collections
je me suis dit que c'était une autre
culture et puis j'ai fini par comprendre
que la merde de yack est un excellent
combustible pour se chauffer et pour
cuisiner j'apprends ici et ça c'est ça
c'est important que s'humecter
délicatement le visage avec leur hymne
d'une grand-mère permet de faire baisser
la fièvre de manière drastique et pour
ça en fait j'ai décidé de les croire sur
parole les nomades n'explique des choses
fondamentales qu'on oublie quand on vit
en ville
en fait je réalise que force d'être
entouré depuis ma naissance par des
magasins remplis de vêtements remplis de
nourriture par des gros bâtiment par du
béton que je suis complètement coupée de
l'origine des choses je vis ce voyage
plein d'énergie plein dans l'aude
enthousiasme je commence à m'intéresser
de loin l'écologie ai je fait part d'un
optimisme un peu niais je me dis qu'un
peu de bonne volonté
quelques éoliennes et des poubelles
multicolores résoudre le problème
changer le monde ait la moindre des
ambitions tout est possible tout est
possible de retour à paris après trois
mois dans la nature
la rupture est brutale
pour la première fois je prends
conscience que la civilisation est une
bulle où l'homme se croient maîtres et
possesseurs de la nature
le problème mais saute à la gueule
l'homme appartient à la nature il l'a
oublié
je découvre la réalité du monde
premier choc en 23 ans direction
l'alaska cette fois ci je ne pars plus
pour sauver le monde mais pour le fuir
une intuition un peu flou mais très
puissante qui grandit en moi
en fait je pense que nos sociétés sont
folles et que le monde court à la
catastrophe dans mon carnet de voyage
j'écris je vois la civilisation comme
une feuille qui vient de se détacher de
sa branche elle perd vol tels trois
volets elle se croit libre affranchi de
son socle
puis elle s'écrase sur les sols et
s'aperçoit que depuis tout ce temps elle
était déjà morte
de retour à paris je m'intéresse d'un
peu plus près à l'état de la planète
puis des rapports scientifiques 60% des
animaux sauvages exterminés en 40 ans
80% des insectes européen exterminés en
30 ans 200 espèces exterminer chaque
jour la pollution la déforestation les
océans keith vie de la fonte des glaces
exploitation démentent des ressources
naturelles
livre après livre article après article
je découvre que le vivant soit ce qui
rend notre planète unique dans tout
l'univers moeurs et ils meurent de plus
en plus vite
en fait je réalise qu'on est tous dans
un avion en première classe que le
champagne coule à flot que les mets les
plus exquises sont servis en abondance
tout le monde fait la fête
convaincu de vivre une époque formidable
le seul problème est que l'avion est en
train de se crasher et que personne ne
regarde par le hublot
second choc est beaucoup plus brutale
celui-là fini par être convaincu qu'on
se dirige droit vers la fin du monde que
l'humanité disparaîtra en emportant avec
elle une immense partie du vivant est le
plus terrible c'est que plus la science
nous apporte les preuves de la
catastrophe plus la destruction
s'accélère alors mon optimisme les
places un désespoir total
l'année suivante je repars en expédition
pour traverser la chaîne de l'himalaya à
pied c'est le moyen pour moi de
reprendre des forces
ça me permet de tenir de me calmer votre
voyage décide de me séparer tous les
objets industriels de mon de mon sac à
dos et de la remplacer par la nature
pendant quatre mois je marche seul dans
les montagnes je suis accompagné par ce
beau petit cheval blanc que je nomme
robert et qui s'avère bien plus
équilibrée et sympathique que l'autre
taré qui m'avaient accompagné en
mongolie
je rencontre les nomades tibétains et
les derniers chasseurs cueilleurs d'asie
ces rencontres ne redonne foi en l'homme
elle me rappelle qu'il existe des
humains capables de vivre en harmonie
avec la nature
une vie sans détruire toutes les autres
est possible en ville je deviens vite
misanthrope dans la nature
c'est rare rencontre me font aimer les
hommes
la solitude est la plus grande des
humanistes fini ce voyage avec un
tacticien en bambou de peau de chèvre en
guise de manteaux j'arrivais à me
séparer de ma tante en dormant dans des
grottes et pour la première fois de ma
vie je parviens à faire du feu par
friction
je me sens libre apaisé comme si j'avais
retrouvé un équilibre sur la crête des
montagnes je remplis mais poumon
d'oxygène pour pouvoir tenir en apnée à
mon retour avant de repartir en fait
c'est en ville que je survis et dans le
sauvage que je vis pleinement de retour
à paris je reprends ma double vie ce
perpétuel décalage entre la partie de
mon cerveau qui sait que tout empire de
jour en jour et l'autre qui va avoir des
coups avec ses potes qui essaye de vivre
en société sans trop se faire remarquer
et là
figurez vous que c'est braves gens de
tedx narbonne me contacter pour me
proposer une conférence
alors j'ai tout de suite pensé à une
introduction superbe à un truc inspirant
un message d'espoir je dirais qu'ils
faisaient quelque chose comme on va tous
crever tedx ou pathétique ça ne sert
strictement à rien mais rien du tout
quoi
et bizarrement les les organisateurs
n'ont pas été si emballé que ça par
cette idée donc j'essaye de creuser un
peu qu'est ce que je fais pourquoi je le
fais en fait là
je me pose pour la première fois c'est
comment vivre à 25 ans dans un monde qui
meurt je réalise que je vais dans la
nature comme si j'allais sur une autre
planète
plus aucun lien entre la vie que je mène
ici à paris et là bas sur la planète
sauvage
rien ne passe entre les deux mondes j'ai
fermé la porte
je ressens un sentiment d'urgence
je cherche des réponses je rencontre des
gens qui sont conscients de la situation
je découvre que je suis pas seul et ça
fait un bien fou
malgré leur connaissance de la situation
ils veulent se battre résister
construire l'avenir des choses qui me
paraissait complètement farfelu encore
très récemment il ya trois mois en août
dernier je repars en expédition pour
traverser la jungle amazonienne
alors l'objectif est toujours le même me
séparer de tous les objets de mon sac à
dos tout ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
je me fais arrêter
les gendarmes ils m'apprennent que la
zone de la jungle où je me trouve est
interdite
j'ai donc trois options 1 est bien passé
le barrage va me faire opérer de changer
d'itinéraire ou 3 est rentrée à paris
je choisi de changer d'itinéraire et la
veille de mon nouveau départ je me
réveille en sursaut et je vois un homme
partir en courant avec toutes mes
affaires dans ses mains je me retrouve
donc à poil dans la jungle sans rien
alors moi qu'il voulait me dépossédés de
tout les affaires de mon sac à dos je
pense qu'on peut dire que cette
expédition est une véritable réussite et
le lendemain je me rends compte que le
lieu où j'ai installé mon hamac
s'appelle le terminus ça peut vraiment
le terminus
alors quand on finit nue en pleine nuit
dans la jungle amazonienne
c'est en général un bon moyen pour se
remettre en question pour pour faire un
petit point sur sa vie quoi et c'est ce
que j'ai fait je suis obligé de rentrer
prématurément
qu'est ce que ça serait peut-être que
c'est l'occasion de réunir ces deux
mondes
ou plutôt ses deux mois celui qui survit
en ville et qui vit dans la nature
et je crois que c'est ça il faut que
j'arrive à vivre
aussi quand je suis de retour dans la
civilisation que je fasse preuve de la
même énergie de la même combativité de
la même envie qu'un expédition le voyage
continue à mon retour je ne veux plus
fuir ni oublier les réelles il est temps
que je lui fasse face en fait c'était
m'a permis de venir à bout d'une
expédition bien plus difficile qui
durait depuis des années maintenant un
genre d'expédition intérieur prendre la
mesure de la catastrophe m'a assommé
puis désespéré et finalement elle me
remets en capacité d'agir
souvenez vous du jour de mes funérailles
en alaska et du discours de mon texte de
mon père sur la vie brève et excitante
d'achille que j'aurais mener pour lui
répondre
si je pars dans la nature c'est pour
vivre sobrement loin de l'excitation et
de la démesure de la civilisation c'est
elle qui a choisi de mener une vie brève
excitante comme achille mais j'ai bien
l'impression que la réalité nous
rattrape et qu'on arrive à la fin de
cette brève grandeur et leur bordel on
n'a toujours pas répondu à la question
comment vivre à 25 ans dans un monde qui
meurt est-ce que vous pensez que la
solution est d'aller sur une autre
planète
et bien moi je pense qu'on vit déjà
comme si on vivait sur une autre planète
alors je préfère revenir sur terre et
défense qui reste à défendre la bonne
nouvelle c'est que quelque chose
d'immense se bat nos côtés c'est
l'ensemble du vivant qui veut
désespérément vivre c'est la minuscule
racing qui s'attaque aux plus grands des
barrages c'est la fleur qui pousse sur
le trottoir c'est laurent autant qu'ils
s'attaquent aux pelleteuses qui
dévastent son père et son territoire
cédé à 10 qui défendent la vie sauvage à
notre dame des landes est ailleurs tous
ces êtres lutte de toutes leurs forces
contre l'effondrement
tous veulent respirer tous veulent
pousser tous veulent vivre j'ai appris
récemment que le mot courage vient du
mot coeur comme le dit d
johnsen léman vital du courage et bien
sûr l'amour et nous avons besoin de tout
le courage dont le coeur humain est
capable pour défendre ce qu'il reste de
cette planète
il ne manque plus que la résistance
humaine pour mettre fin à cette
destruction qui dure depuis trop
longtemps
la terre entière résiste tous les êtres
vivants résistent ils sont dans notre
camp et nous n'avons pas les rejoindre
au travail
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]